mexico
um
[Music]
i have with me david pakman he is a
progressive host
an executive producer of the
nationally syndicated radio and tv
program the david packman show
and i wanted to talk to david pakman
he is a beta male 1
[Music]
david pacman
he is
david packman
he is a baby
[Music]
[Music]
can you remind the audience when you
talk about being a beta male and being
an alpha male what are we talking about
here
there are males most men today
they think and act like a woman they're
emotional
they are mentally off they have no logic
and that's a beta male they go along
with homosexuality hold on but holy whoa
whoa jesse well we gotta that's a lot
that's a lot hang on agree with
everything that's raw abortion they
think and act just like a woman a beta
male died but a non-beta bill doesn't
because he's a logical thinking
and they're controlled by the darkness
of david pacman
he is a baby
[Music]
david pacman
he is
[Music]
he is a beta male 1
[Music]
david pacman
he is a male 1
david pacman
he
[Music]
david
is
he is they made him well
david you're not here to communicate i
really appreciate you coming out i'm
going to let you go it's a waste of time
to talk to you we're not communicating
you're actually like because you're
asking bizarre questions you're actually
like an idiot and you're wasting my time
i appreciate that
all right
goodbye goodbye
[Music]
trump was doing this
[Music]
we're looking very strongly at sinks and
showers elements of bathrooms
ten times
elements of bathrooms
what on earth is going on with trump and
toilets
trump's white house toilet
[Music]
would be clogged
clogged
[Music]
with documents that donald trump was
flushing down the toilet
is this the explanation is this the
explanation
the big massive dumpster
elements of bathrooms
[Music]
ten times
[Music]
[Music]
god bless the united states thank you
very much elements of bathrooms
mangoes my bags are mangoes
[Music]
i love mangoes too nine cents okay
now that we are up under our bodies
regime
my bag of mangoes now cost 11.
and 99
that seems like a pretty good deal a bag
of mangoes mango aren't mangoes like
three by seas
that's it
eight or eleven bucks
and highway robbery is what you do
[Music]
bring my mangoes back down
[Music]
[Music]
the wisconsin crowd identifying from the
mangoes
forcefully affected the american
[Music]
highway robbery is what you're doing
[Music]
welcome everybody we are very closely
monitoring a bald eagle in a tree um one
little bald eagle has just uh hatched
and it's sitting on another egg and uh
we are keeping an extremely close eye on
it um with all angles of coverage coming
in
but uh the eagle has been born one of
them has been born and it's it's pretty
remarkable what's going on no actually
somehow i came across this stream when
getting ready for my stream oh look at
the look at the eagle rocking do you see
did you guys see that rocking motion
there
very interesting uh animal behavior here
somehow only nine people are watching
this stream i don't even know what it is
i don't know why it was recommended to
me but i do like it i do like it and um
we don't know what will happen with the
other egg right now
but um
so that's happening we are also watching
the sentencing of jesse smallette or
smallit
this is the 2019
fake
hate crime the hate crime hoax
my view
is this needs to be taken
very seriously and for those who may not
remember what this was about
um actor jesse smallett
back in 2019 this was
days before
wait no what year no no this was a year
before the pandemic not days before the
pandemic this was the year before the
pandemic the american actor jesse
smallett reported to chicago pd
that he had been the victim of a hate
crime and it turns out he staged the
hate crime with two nigerian american
brothers who were extras
on empire which is the show that actor
jesse smallett
acted in
and smullet arranged for the brothers to
attack him while wearing ski masks
and arranged for them to shout racial
and homophobic slurs poor bleach on him
put a noose around his neck
and
he not only reported it but said one of
the people who did it was white
now i i find this all despicable
i find it all despicable but as a just
as a as a minor detail
if you stage a racist hate crime
and you're black
wouldn't you hire white people to do it
like what i mean is it seems like such
an unforced error
to get black guys to attack you
and then claim oh i mean it's it's it's
horrible on all levels but it also is
like he's not exactly a criminal genius
i guess we would say um in any case
police started to get suspicious
and it turns out that he staged it and
we are now
standing by
uh at the sentencing hearing let's just
listen to a little bit and now here's
here's my uh my take on this okay
this needs to be taken very seriously
because the right
loves to say
there's constantly false reports of rape
and hate crimes and all these different
things now you know
and i know we all know
we all know there is almost no fake
reporting of crimes and in fact it's the
opposite there's probably under
reporting because of stigma shame
worry that the police won't believe me
worry that my family will be a bit you
know all this different stuff
so
when this does happen
it has to be taken very seriously let's
listen a little bit to the arguments
here this is the sentencing of jesse
smallett he told him what to buy
what
derogatory homophobic racial slurs to
utter to try to pretend as if there's
whites involved by yelling out mega
country he owned every bit of the plan
and he worked hard on it he planned it
out
and he executed on it and he owns that
for doing that
and so
yes it is serious misconduct on his part
and it had broad ramifications and
the the true victims are of course
number one the true
hate crime victims that are not going to
report these crimes they are the true
victims the police department though is
a victim and i'm going to talk about
that okay so we're going to continue
monitoring this i have so many other
things to get to but we are we are going
to monitor that uh pustane pete says
david sir i've retained whitney as legal
counsel i've been audited 10 to 15 times
because of your coupon codes call
whitney to discuss terms we'll do that
and austin said david sur did the judge
offer calzones i don't know i haven't
been following this case so i don't know
if the judge here has been as
accommodating when it comes to food
during the trial by the way how are the
calzones the food is here let's take a
break lunch is here pizza is here but we
have subway tomorrow
warm food around noon yeah
uh
anyway
we um we're gonna continue we're gonna
continue monitoring this the latest news
out of ukraine
um
it's the daily mail reporting okay but
still
putin begins to move on kiev russian
tank column repelled
and another top commander killed in a
devastating ambush
as moscow's forces move within a few
miles of capital outskirts amid fears
that the mariopol bombings are a sign of
what is to come russia attacked kiev
from west and east wednesday as analysts
say the battle for the capital is now
underway
footage showed a russian assault from
the east was ambushed by artillery and
suffered heavy losses
interior ministries said it was a
difficult night in earpin
to the west of the capital excuse me uh
some funny some funny chat happening but
ukrainian forces counter attack through
the morning
there are fears that the capital could
soon be under heavy bombardment yeah so
that's on the one hand what's going on
and it is now
uh six i guess it's one a.m
in ukraine
um meanwhile
increasingly oh wait that's for later
after ukraine
europe wonders who is the next russian
target
and that's a serious question
uh for some european countries watching
russia's brutal war in ukraine there are
fears they could be next
western officials say the most
vulnerable could be those who aren't
members of nato or the eu and are thus
alone and unprotected that includes the
ukrainian neighbor moldova
russia's neighbor georgia
both of them formerly part of the ussr
along with the balkan states
of bosnia and kosovo
analysts warn even nato members could be
at risk such as estonia latvia and
lithuania i would it would be
devastating if any of those three
countries were uh the subject of russian
hostility
i happen to have a soft spot for estonia
i've spent time in
estonia
loved it
absolutely loved it great people and i'm
sure the people everywhere are great i'm
just saying i know about the people
in uh in estonia really really uh i mean
it's
it's all crazy
um i see that our twitch subs thing has
sort of gone off the screen let me see
if i can deal with that
and you know why it is because we've
gotten to a thousand there it is
beautiful
beautiful okay we got it
so concerns about russian ambitions
going uh going beyond ukraine and of
course that's been a concern
for a long time
um in the meantime the price of oil
has come down a bit as you can see here
we've now had a two-day decline
where oil peaked at
114
oh wait no that's the one day sorry oil
peaked at 127 and is down to 105.
so about a 15 percent decline in the
price of oil and that is a good thing i
mean it's so you know you know but if we
i'm not an investor in oil i'm just
thinking of what is happening right now
with gas prices and what's happening
with shipping and what's going to be
happening and it's not good this is not
your typical
gas is up 20 cents and republicans cry
and we're like that's an average of
another dollar fifty a month for most
people that's not what we're talking
about right now
right about a dramatic increase
and so crude oil coming back down a
little bit
you know to say that a higher or lower
commodity price is good or bad
ignores the complexity of
so much of how the economy works but i
actually would say it's good that the
prices come down a little bit
uh so we're following that
um what i don't know that i had anything
here
oh the u.s has seen russia increasingly
firing weapons from a distance
using long-range fires bombardment
missile launches from aircraft and
mobile missile launchers
um and increasingly hitting populated
areas so
again
i see no simple off-ramp for putin given
his personality
and when you see that they are creeping
closer closer closer
to
kiev
and they are starting to bombard from
further further further away
to me this doesn't look like we've got
48 hours left and then it's all gonna be
fine i'm not expecting rainbows ginger
snaps and singing kumbaya
in three days
given the the direction that this seems
to be going and of course i'm always
more than willing to hear
different opinions
from people in my uh people in my
audience i want to say thank you to
windup cat and abe froman for the twitch
prime subscriptions numbers one and two
today also a huge thank you to sarah
beth
i think the last name is pronounced bead
i hope that's that's right sarah beth
thank you sarah beth is the first person
to sign up on my website today
and his new member number three
i uh i know that there are
anxious people
hoping for some voicemails today
i will get to voicemails it's been so
busy lately we just we just haven't been
able to quite frankly
um but we're going to get to that but i
do have some other things first of all i
know that this is really late in the
game
but
if you live near florence south carolina
or even near florence south carolina
trump's holding a rally there saturday
that's in
in two days
we would love to have a correspondent
there okay so if you live nearby
if you have at least a phone and some
kind of mic you can attach because the
last time we did this the audio quality
was not good with the ambient noise when
people didn't have mics if you can get
there you got to get yourself registered
you got to figure out how to get there
we'll pay you to go okay we want someone
there doing interviews who can connect
connect with us via skype and
we it went so well when we did it in
texas
was it texas or arizona no it was texas
yeah if you live close enough to
florence south carolina and you can get
there saturday please email info
davidpakman.com
subject florence
rally
florence rally
um we'll pay you to go we just need one
person okay and you you
you've got to get there and do all the
stuff but
we'll pay you so you can email
uh what else do we have here oh so
madison cawthorne who recently was
charged with driving without a valid
license
for the second time
okay after being pulled over for driving
over the center line
okay
he now has started to go kind of in a
more pro-putin direction again which we
expected some of these clowns to do
here's what he recently had to say about
the ukrainian president zelinski
so they can defend themselves better but
remember that zielinski is a thug
remember the ukrainian government is
incredibly corrupt and it is incredibly
evil it has been pushing woke ideologies
and it really does the new world okay so
three things
is there corruption in ukraine yes is
there more corruption in russia
absolutely
okay
uh
is there any thuggery in ukraine yes is
there way more dangerous thuggery in
russia of course
and is it true that ukraine is pushing
woke ideology no it's just not as
overtly
homophobic and transphobic
as russia
okay this is an insufferable clown
and uh lindsey graham
clearly is not thrilled with the cothorn
wing of the republican party you'll
remember that when marjorie taylor green
and lauren beau bear
during the state of the union yelled out
very very disgustingly
looney lindsay as we used to know him
said shut up
uh he also doesn't seem to like uh corn
putin
there's a poll coming out tonight i'm
aware of where putin's approval rating
is 0.7
now i don't know who these people are
but they're not a lot of them
i think the average republican and
democrat in this country would give high
marks to zielinski
do a poll i've seen these polls
what putin has done is done something we
can't do among ourselves
like 90 of the country is with the
ukrainians
and as opposed to putin so when you see
a member of congress say things like
this the one thing i want you to know
there are outliers
in the largest sense possible on our
side and there are some on the left
that are outliers
so let's end with this thought that
america believes
that zelinski and the ukrainians are the
good guys all right so anyway he says
that the perspective of um madison
cawthorne
is an outlier and uh that that does
appear to be true generally speaking
right now at least in terms of uh of
what's being said publicly i think he's
right about that
um
okay other super chats david sir who's
your favorite drummer
i love matt garstka i don't have one
favorite drummer it really depends on
the genre
um but there's so many great drummers
right i mean if you want to talk about
uh people like vinnie kaliyuda and steve
gadd and that entire generation you've
got a whole bunch of great people there
and then you know if you look at uh uh
punk or
it just really depends on on the genre
steve smith is great carter beauford
from dave matthews band and
um mike portnoy from i guess what would
be called progressive rock uh bonham of
course how you know
um
there's just so many there's just so
many there's it's sort of like saying to
anybody who reads what's your favorite
book you know
very very tough
question to uh answer
in such a concise way
thanks to jen here for gifting a twitch
subscription i appreciate that jen also
big thank you to andre thompson andre
just did something very very special
andre signed up on my website
joinedpakman.com
with the coupon code obama
when you use that code you save and
everybody wins i do have one new element
on my sound board and it's from that
really strange trump interview with the
ufc prank guys hold on i'm coming right
that's the new that's the new uh
the new trump
element that i have i think that's all
in terms of new stuff
i do have this the best is yet to come
okay
so uh
that might be useful on saturday when we
cover the trump rally okay let's
continue
here's a guy
in the trucker convoy
interviewed by andrew callahan
and he says he says putin's a good guy
putin's the good guy here people are
pretty sympathetic and supportive of
putin
why has this change occurred
well the deep state
has always made putin to look like the
bad guy
but he's a good guy he's taken out all
the um
the bio labs
child trafficking areas um these are all
lies by the way
whoa look at this guy's eyes something
we i just paused it in a weird spot but
something's up with this guy's eyes huh
that's weird
maybe it's maybe that's a medical
condition i don't know
run the chrome harvesting areas
wait did he say adrenochrome what was
that word he used
adrenochrome harvesting areas if people
would have watched when trump came into
office right at the beginning when you
saw them hand that
soccer ball off that soccer ball had
some soccer ball much information in it
to take down
everybody that that oh that's i've never
heard that
there was information in the soccer ball
which uh
wow that's a pretty slick way of getting
trump what he needs had so much
information in it to take down
everybody that that putin's been getting
all the intel on for years right it had
a lot of data in it
data
yeah by the way that uk this ukraine
summit that he's referencing here i'm
sorry the ukraine summit uh finland
summit
this was when trump came out and said
listen i asked him if russia did any
hacking and putin said he didn't he
denied it very strongly so i don't i
just don't i just don't think so so that
guy's out of his mind um here is lauren
beau bear
i don't know what kind of joke she's
trying to make here about joe biden's
not really running the country
but it falls very flat work not opec and
i don't know who's running the federal
government these days uh joe biden or
prince john uh from uh
uh prince john but they're taxing us
into
[Laughter]
anybody know what that's about
what does that mean
like what was she even trying to say
i don't
know i i genuinely have no idea what the
joke was even supposed to be
very bizarre uh larry says via super
chat kawthorne is super dangerous still
ridiculous but very scary i consider him
a huge threat also are you a fan of matt
cameron or danny carey
only in the most casual way
david sir any concern the supreme court
will decay declare the obama discount
code unconstitutional i'm worried i am
very worried about that yeah
no i'm worried
dude's eyes cocked like a pistol yeah it
was strange it was very strange should
we give this one more listen to see if
we can figure out what the joke was
supposed to be work not opec and i don't
know who's running the federal
government these days uh joe biden or
prince john uh from uh uh
uh prince john but um
who is like if i just google prince john
what do i find
prince john was the fifth
hold on let's see here prince john of
the united kingdom was the fifth son and
youngest of the six children of king
george v and queen mary
anybody know what that's about
robin hood movie
prince john
robin hood let's see
prince john is the main antagonist
of disney's film robin hood
he's the younger brother of king richard
from whom john usurped the throne of
england
man i don't even i don't even know
john is reviled by his subjects for
stealing from the poor
to heighten his own wealth and
prosperity doesn't even make sense
because they like to say democrats want
to steal from the rich
well i don't know it's it's all very
strange very very strange
uh
let's check in a little bit here on the
jessie smallet sentencing
talking about the time wasted by the
chicago police force
time wasted by the city of chicago
he also spent time talking about the
impact this could have
on the lgbt community
but there are problems with that of
course judge
because i searched the disorderly
conduct statute
the entire team did
and i was searching to see if there was
any aggravation or enhancement ladder
that our legislature in springfield put
in place
for class okay so they're continuing to
argue over what kind of sentence actor
jesse smallett should get
and we'll continue we'll continue
looking at that um thank you to eldoc
for the twitch prime subscription i very
much appreciate that i appreciate you
being here a few other super chats
coming in president of cameroon paul bia
says david sir you should try to get on
h3's leftover podcast i think it would
be bigly entertaining i i would do it
anytime you know i was in la not long
ago and it was right at the end of the
year and ethan klein said that they were
off
uh that week the week i was there so
that didn't work out but i would be i
would love to be there anytime
um is the prince john reference trying
to say biden usurped the presidency from
trump maybe i mean is lauren bobert that
smart
i don't know
i don't even know if that's
what it would be it's it's all very
strange very very strange
let's look at um
okay let we'll listen to a couple
voicemails yeah let's yeah i i'm at 1100
voicemail so let's listen to a few of
them here's eric from mass
hey david it's eric from mass what
happened with the bio labs i thought
that was a conspiracy theory oh i
thought the pfizer fiverr documents were
a conspiracy theory nine pages of
uh side effects
and you walked all your dum-dums into uh
the hospital and the grave hmm
okay here's troy york
david pakman um you're so actually i'm i
i'm so bored with troy york i don't even
i'm reading ahead of i don't even want
to play this voicemail because it's
actually so weaponized let's listen to a
different one from troy york
um basically stephen colbert
is worth 75 million dollars
and get 15 million dollars
for the
horrendous unfunded program
um
global corporate network
and the audacity of this i i just could
not care less about stephen colbert i
really couldn't it's just like okay what
whatever
um here's one from whitney
so i i found out that macron had more to
say um after i looked through a lot of
articles because i saw one and i was
like that was crazy
um
but also
on the ukraine issue i was noticing that
um
russia kind of like
uh
had a good tactic in mind when
surrendering surrendering some of their
wow whitney now weighing in on military
strategy very very interesting that's
that's pretty fascinating
well the pacman i have two points first
of all london sandus um no matter what
the left what you left to say
he was not bullying those kids who were
wearing masks it was actually giving
them the freedom not to be bullied
by the administrators no he bullied them
into taking off their masks
he bullied them into taking them off
so i really think that entj is like
really unreal yeah i still don't care
about myers-briggs
david paxton and this is dave berkshire
hi how's it going
hey i think the reason people call and
expect you to defend communism is
because
us follows a bias in everything you do
against conservatives or republicans
and it makes people assume you're on
communist well that makes them very
stupid
most people who think the american right
wing is bonkers are not communists so it
would be a stupid assumption to make
that because i think madison cawthorne's
a [ __ ]
i'm a communist
kg says hoping someone makes a mashup
video with a conversation between the
wisconsin nail salon caller and whitney
that would be a pretty that would be
pretty good
that would that would be very very good
eric from mass continuing to call back
hey david it's eric from mass
fizer
documents
3
mortality rate 93
imagine being so deluded that you
believe 3 out of every 100 people who
got the vaccine died
like imagine imagine being that stupid
how many people have gotten the vaccine
in the united states right now
uh i mean i guess if there's 331 million
and what is it like 85 percent got one
dose or 80 percent got one dose
and three percent of them died that
means there's nearly eight million
people that died that we've heard
nothing about they're just i i guess
they they just disappeared
um
it's
completely crazy imagine being that
that deluded
so i figured out what um the
similarities between the aries and the
tourists so not only do i not care about
myers-briggs i also don't care about
astrology whitney with p with total
peace and love i say that to you okay
we're not gonna do uh we're not gonna do
astrology stuff either okay here is a
man at the clark county school board
meeting
invoking black history month and
imploring teachers to teach about hulk
lawyer a black confederate soldier under
general vines
this may be a psychotic break
tonight was a special night there was a
lot of young people that were here
um
tonight was special
um
but mainly in uh first
for um
february i would like to talk about uh
black uh history month
in honor of black history month i will
be speaking about
confederate black confederate history
of this uh confederate boy he was 14
years old his name was hulk uh
lawyer hulk
why do they say
confederate isn't the word confederate
there's a picture of him he joined the
confederacy
under his general uh vines
as a free free 14 year old boy
and just to let you guys know that
state requirements uh is
ccsd has to teach
on civil war and reconstruction age
hulk lawyer died in 1936. this guy
doesn't exist this guy just doesn't
exist the guy he's referring to
live through reconstruction and that
many point of views if you guys talk
about diversity why don't you talk about
hulk lawyer and his point of view
because he died proudly a confederate
so anyways that's just something for the
school teacher maybe this guy has a cold
and that's why it sounds so weird school
teachers and everyone else
whoa thank you from carlow
wow
um white man honors
black confederate history icon hulk
lawyer
but there is no such person
according to civil war historian kevin
levin
it is more likely that the person
mentioned was holt collier okay so who's
holt collier
holt collier was a noted
african-american bear
hunter
uh
okay
but was he a confederate
it's all pretty weird
holt collier hulk lawyer
man that how weird is that huh
that is just bizarre
so okay that happened
here's something really weird
jimmy dore bizarrely claims popular
music critic anthony fantano is behind
ukraine invasion
uh i want to find
jimmy dore
bizarrely claims popular
music critic let me just find this
article
um
where is this
i'm actually not finding the article
is behind ukraine invasion
is this a joke
maybe it's not even real
let's see
i actually can't find the article maybe
this is actually fake
it's real oh this is this is this a real
story
i'm not able to find it so maybe it is
not real
let's see
huffpost
and i don't even know how to search on
huffpost the web the huffpost website is
completely toxic
jimmy
door anthony fantano
yeah i actually can't find it maybe this
is a parody
well i don't know
maybe it was yeah i just have no idea in
a bizarre explicative oh well no this
can't be real explicative
i think it's probably fake
okay
well whatever who knows
um great oh they've been going really
hard on fox news against kamala harris
lately and it's starting to get
kind of like beyond just a just a policy
critique take a listen to this and and
putin is thinking yeah maybe this wasn't
such a good idea
is that what putin's thinking greg i
think that putin realizes that we're not
in it to win it right we wouldn't have
sent her she's great for us this show
but she's lousy for this job she makes
us laugh but her laugh is so unsettling
because it wasn't she wasn't laughing
about it an obvious thing that other
people could see it was also it was an
inside joke of sorts so it just is kind
of like what are they doing up there
right now this this is like the least
funny guy on fox and i think he's
supposed to be the only funny guy
i don't understand it she's like a child
she's on a big trip she's like a child
who's allowed to see the cockpit but you
better not touch anything please don't
touch any of the buttons she's not
allowed to have any any impact on
anything because she's not to be you
know they don't trust her she is right
now a polish joke and i love that she
said full stop what
she's a polish joke
what the hell like she's like in poland
they see her as a joke is that what he
means i don't even know
is this comedy or is this real i don't
know news i don't even know but um yeah
but do you think when you
now that's the that's the unserious
stuff the serious stuff and the sad part
is this is
a symbolic virtue signal that is
replacing real activity we do not need
this sort of emblem as what she was
referred to she's an emblem of our
concern we need a shocking audacious
diplomatic effort and we need it swiftly
i've talked about it before you know
we've said we spent a lot of time and
billions of dollars in the ukraine now
they need us
the ukraine does anybody know what this
guy's talking about like why is he still
even saying the ukraine and he wants us
to think kamal is the one who doesn't
know what's going on
20 years of saying the ukraine i don't
know what he's talking about
we gotta send our very best there not
the joker in a pant suit we need obama
we need trump we need bush they gotta go
one of two the combination because we
need mediation on steroids that
expresses how much the world is
disgusted by this and how
intent we are on stopping the bloodshed
and potential world war three without
that by doing this this only prolongs it
this prolongs the suffering and and it
makes us look like we don't care
can i
anybody know what so what's the analysis
that
kamala is bad
and we
wow um this wasn't it then jesse waters
uh hosted janine pirro who says kamala
has the intellectual horsepower of a
fourth grader
surround the capital zielinski's in deep
trouble if he can't hold these guys off
soon and it's you know they're going to
starve them out and they're going to
send in assassins we don't have a lot of
time we have to do something
more than we're doing right now well you
know dana given the fact that she i
can't tell if this stuff is because
kamala's a woman or because she's quote
black even though it's you know she
she's half south asian half jamaican i i
can't tell which why they're doing this
don't even have the cape the ability to
say yes we will accept refugees when
she's in charge of the border uh is is
really it's stunning i mean she has the
like the intellectual horsepower of a
fourth grader i mean
why is she there didn't she know that
she'd be asked these questions i
um i wouldn't i think that she was sent
there
on a mission and that was
okay
um it's it's
getting getting pretty pretty bad there
uh here's another one of these
interviews of the bill barr book tour
the billbar book tour
includes
bill barr telling horrifying stories
about trump but then saying i'd still
vote for him over a democrat and here
bill barb bizarrely says that 78 years
old is too old to govern for joe biden
[Music]
but donald trump is currently
almost 76
and would be almost
he'd be older than biden is now when
barr said he'd vote for him again in
2024 i mean it's all
if he was the nominee
well i didn't exactly say that but but
but you know i think i said look uh
i i think he'd be making a grave mistake
if he was nominated i hope he isn't
uh if at the end of the day
he's the republican nominee
you know while it's hard to see
everything over the next three years
i think the greatest threat to the
country
is the progressive agenda that's
dominating the democratic party and it's
hard for me to conceive i would ever not
vote for the republican
candidate that would to me be sort of
the choice between the lesser of two
evils is there someone out there that
you see you said you think it should be
someone younger who you would want to
see be the nominee i think there's
[Music]
by the way why
why are their microphones so echoey are
you guys hearing that it's like this is
the this is
one of the most profitable profitable
media entities in the united states and
what's what's with the echo it's very
strange the republicans are blessed with
a lot of qualified people and
many of them would be
great presidents and i'm scratching my
head as to why we've had four baby boom
presidents in a row
and then instead of moving on to the
next generation we go back to a pre-baby
boomer and in biden you know it's time
for other people to step up and there's
a lot of talent there you think he's too
old to govern
who biden
yes
uh you know people age at different
paces and and uh he's an old
78 is he
he's an old 78 and i i think he's too
old to govern personally i mean trump
would be 79 it's
this is all very very strange
also wasn't obama like 44 when he became
president
46 what was it anybody remember
so what's next for bill barr you've done
a lot of things it's a 600 page book and
it goes back to your time at the cia and
600 pages can you imagine
being a china scholar and all of your
history what's next for you what do you
hope to still do
have fun
i packed a lot into 72 years play some
bagpipes play bagpipes yeah dilvar thank
you very much well he's certainly full
of plenty of hot air that i would
imagine he can really uh pound out those
uh those bagpipes what what a bizarre
whole thing now a bunch of you have
emailed me over the last few days about
william barr
here's some of the things that some of
you guys have said number one
barr is helping trump set up an insanity
defense by claiming trump really
believed the stuff that he was saying
that's one
one opinion from a handful of you
another one is barr is actually doing
this specifically to help set up someone
else like maybe desantis or maybe
someone
less obviously insane
um i don't know i think he's just trying
to sell sell books i think that that's
that's basically what it is at the end
of the day
the way uh here's a super chat the way
americans pronounced putin sounds like
the german word for turkey
yeah some people say putin
and some say putin but then people like
madison cawthorne seem to be saying
boudin like as if it were b-u-d-i-n
boudin
boudin
hillary says
david sur as as do you have thoughts on
how we can help the refugees of ukraine
i think at this point all we can really
do is donate
to
entities that we that we trust
connor says parkman sir i asked this on
the last stream but it disappeared are
you an atheist long time supporter
member and i've always wondered this i
don't know whether i'm atheist or
agnostic i'm open to the the idea that
there is
um some kind of uh
higher power but that i am as open to
that being
some kind of technology
overlords as i am it's a uh
a personal god as some say
um i i for for me i've seen no more
evidence
that there's a god
then that we're in a simulation
or
that we're someone's science experiment
i i don't know
um so i don't know what that makes me
but i'm and people will say oh but david
sir you know you talk about latkes and
canisius and uh kugel and you're making
borscht and what it sounds like you're
i'm culturally jewish
ethnically jewish
and culinarily jewish
um but i'm not i'm not a religious
person
see what else we've got here
chandler says sir does my love of ginger
snaps
make me an old 44 year old i don't know
i had a ginger molasses cookie the other
day
uh it's a it's an interesting cookie
it's it's not ever what i would choose
you know
um but it was it was an interesting
cookie i i can't say i hated it can't
say i hated it okay uh okay hold on so
let's see my phone is blowing up is it
relevant to what i'm doing here it is
not okay so i don't need to pay
attention to that uh will i open the
phones today
maybe i don't know i mean we're not
we're
we're pathetically at six out of a
hundred website members and twitch
subscribers so let me give you guys the
good news and the bad news the good news
is that on the 10th of the month we're
already over a thousand uh twitch
subscribers that's the good news okay
that's the good
the bad is that today we're at six out
of a hundred
i guess i'd be willing to make a deal
with you guys
where instead of targeting a hundred i'd
be willing to move it to fifty so that
puts us already at twelve percent of the
way if we get to 50 i'll open phone
lines and that includes twitch and that
includes the website and just to double
down on it
first person to use the code please
don't war on my website today
joinpacman.com
i'll send you a free coffee mug so i'm
doing everything i can
uh but let let's kind of just see where
we land
other super chats coming in
thoughts on the pfizer document that
shows 1200 vaccine deaths in the first
three months i'm boosted just asking
questions not the [ __ ] tucker way i i
have not seen that
i've not even heard of that i mean i
know that for a year eric from mass has
been
you know emailing in about that
uh let's see pfizer
documents
let's see what that's about
um articles inaccurately claiming 1200
covid vaccine deaths
okay
let's see online articles shared on
social uh let me just pull it up why am
i reading this off screen
let's take a look now mind you guys this
is not me
researching right now i just this is
kind of the first time hearing it and
i'm just going to see what this says
article articles inaccurately claim
document reveals pfizerkova deaths
online articles shared on social media
claim a document released by the fda
revealed more than 1200 deaths related
to the pfizer vaccine in a 90-day period
but the pharmaceutical giant says the
document does not indicate the
fatalities are linked to vaccination and
it concludes the shots are safe oh
okay
so
based only on this one sentence alone
what i would imagine this is about
is that much like for a period of time
any covet any death in someone who had
coveted within 60 days of having coveted
was counted as a coveted death when
really they could have died from
anything
which by the way republicans said that
was being covered up
we were upfront all along about how
these numbers were calculated
massachusetts for example is now
reducing the death toll by about 15
percent because of of that okay
it seems to me that what the documents
show
is that
over a 90-day period there were 1200
vaccinated people who died and of course
when you start with vaccinating the
oldest people and the least healthy
i mean people die
so uh it seems
just based on
one search
that um
it's not true i mean it's you know i
don't know how much time we want to put
into that necessarily
derek says david sir wisquensen will
take 500 000 refugees please with
acrylic tips yes
yes
i want to say thank you to some really
great people including zero cool
who has both gifted and subscribed as
well as ang cole
putting us at nine
also want to say thank you over on the
website a huge accomplishment jacob
aston just signed up on my website with
the coupon code obama
and his new member number 10 still a
free coffee mug available to whoever is
the first person to use the code
please don't war if you sign up with the
coupon code please don't war you will
get a free
coffee mug
other super chats coming in larry says i
actually learned the term ethno-religion
from watching you want to thank you i've
always struggled to explain judaism is a
race and a religion now i can more
easily shalom bro thank you
by the way
you will get crushed in certain circles
for saying judaism is a race i think it
might be better to say it's an ethnicity
although guys we i think we all
understand what's being said but there
are circles who will not
understand that
and one of the simplest ways to explain
it
is
if you are born
to two ethnically jewish parents
and they are also religious
and you quit the religion
you are still ethnically jewish when you
imagine that for example i know people
who are jewish who go through fertility
treatment
you get tested for specific diseases
that are more often carried by ashkenazi
jews just because you stop believing in
the torah
doesn't change that you would still want
to get tested for that stuff so there's
two different things
on the other hand imagine the opposite
imagine you're born into a mormon family
and you convert to judaism
right
you are now religiously jewish
but you don't need to be tested for that
stuff right you're obviously not
ethnically jewish these are two
different things
do people understand this
because it seems so straightforward but
i feel like that it's the source of a
lot of confusion
oh no now there's the whole semi thing
green man i love you but uh yes
semite means one thing
anti-semitism by convention
refers to judaism and i understand if
you want to take what we might call
god i hope green man's not a
fundamentalist etymologist
green man please tell me you're not a
fundamentalist at a model etymologist
oh my god he is
they came to me they said sir green man
is a fundamentalist etymology no okay i
think i think i think we're all clear on
this stuff i don't think we have to
continue
okay good um
a few other memberships dumping in the
free coffee mug goes to adam
kanusky am i pronouncing that correctly
adam adam has signed up on my website
with the coupon code please don't war
adam you get a free coffee mug email
your mailing address to info
davidpakman.com also thanks to gina
redford
hugh
mungus
hillary lee
miguel salazar
andrew
furrow and christina gonzalez all
signing up and putting us at 17.
uh oh and um
yeah yeah the deal we made is we cut the
goal from from 100 to 50 and we'll open
phone lines if we get to 50. we're only
at 17 though which is not it's not great
okay as we wait for the trial to resume
let's get back to a few other voicemails
it's uh it's crazy how many of these
voicemails are coming in
i'm going to do my best to get us
somewhere here
um
let's see here
i hope people like ben shapiro realize
that when you say stuff like lying about
rape is the same as some of the other
nasty [ __ ] [ __ ] that men do that
there's other people here watching
who
aren't legal
and do lots of nasty [ __ ] up [ __ ] to
people okay i think she may start be
starting to describe crimes
so i do want to get away from that
thanks to patrick boyce patrick just
signed up on my website and his new
member number 18 today thank you patrick
i appreciate that
um
let's see what else we've got here's
foreign policy from troy york david
pakman uh your
your assertion that the clean war can
last 10 to 20 years
um ignores the fact that russia's having
sanctions on them they won't be able to
fund it it's so weird
let's test the audience
okay i'm gonna give you guys a test and
i think you guys are gonna pass with
flying colors okay
let's say
that i were to say to you
um
the british foreign ministry
believes
the ukraine russia war could last 10
years
okay
is that my opinion or is that someone
else's opinion i'm the ma i'm telling
you
okay i'm telling you
the british foreign ministry believes
the war could last 10 years
would you say david
your opinion is it could last 10 years
or am i telling you someone else's
opinion
let's see if people pass the test
it's someone else's opinion right
so when troy york calls in to say i'm
wrong that it could last 10 years i'm
reporting
what experts and intelligence agencies
believe
how is this such a complicated thing
okay
thanks to skittlestu for gifting five
subs
putting us at 23. also thanks to
rico b
for signing up via twitch and a big
thank you to elora moeller who just
signed up over on my website guys we are
halfway
if one person dumped in 25 gifted subs
we would open phone lines right now
kb says do you get any normal voicemails
yeah i'll play a normal voicemail for
you okay
uh i'm just now here i'm not going to a
regular caller i'm picking at random
this is just the newest voicemail let's
listen
what's up i got a question
what is the difference
barring
all of the sophisticated equipment that
russia is using to
kill everybody in ukraine what's the
difference between what he's doing
and what and how this country was
acquired
same [ __ ] was going on only the weapons
were different
people came in here and devastated
the indians
the people that lived here yeah so this
is a fair question i mean there's
there's two different answers to that
one is
that was a long time ago when things
were very different it's not a very
satisfying answer uh that that would be
number one number two is
that was also wrong right i mean
you know it's uh i it's
the the problem i have with that is
what does that tell us about what should
be done now and it tells us nothing
it tells us nothing you know that's
that's the difficulty and sort of like
it's it's fine it's fine you know
wow skittle stew has just dumped in
25 25 subscriptions big massive dumps
dumps
and what happened if you watched the
election i was called by the biggest
people
they call them dumps right
uh that puts us at 50 also i want to say
thanks to any 43 who's new member number
51 today and also thank you to syed
ahmad who is new member number 52 today
let's open the phone lines guys i
appreciate that i appreciate that
um zombie says the prince john comment
was a reference to robin hood okay let's
hear from a few a few of you guys i
always stick to my word when we make the
membership goal we open the phone lines
discord is where we do it you go to
davidpakman.com
slash discord and then you go to the
waiting lobby
okay
davidpakman.com discord
waiting lobby
and then
i will pick up
on a few of your phone calls this is
exciting guys as we as we await the
resumption of the trial oh oh oh oh
before we do that
someone sent me this they spotted this
in oklahoma here's a vehicle
where they have i stand with putin on it
1776
trump i back the blue let's go brandon
sheep watch fake news
pure blood generation x patriot raising
lions not sheep
okay
from pedo joe who supports dh dhs
let's go brandon
so this is this is pretty weaponized
they've also got a what is hyundai
japanese or korean
where is hyundai from for this is a very
pro-american person
i forget where hyundai is from
it's korean yeah
uh
yeah
so that happened
that happened all right let's speak to
some people
starting with
shayna from california you're on the air
shayna from california you're on the air
shayna from california you're on the air
all right no shayna
let's go to our friend oh it's tamesha
from new york city to misha how's your
son
tamisha oh i'm not even in the waiting
lobby i'm an idiot oh my god that was my
fault hey tamisha how are you i'm sorry
that was my fault
hi how are you
i didn't even hear you call my name i
know that was that was my fault that was
my fault your son's doing well
yes i have two sons but yes oh okay
well
they're both doing well
what's going on
what was i gonna say
um i've been having withdrawal from not
being able to speak to work
scheduling is prob problematic
well i'm glad you're oh it sounds like
there's some commotion in the background
there
yeah my son
ryan be quiet
okay so what how are things in new york
i hear things are kind of getting back
to normal to some degree
yes things are back to normal which i i
i agree with time i think like the
numbers are significantly low enough to
feel ready for everything to go back to
normal i feel comfortable good
good
what's on your mind today
um i just had a quick story
from an experience i had like i think it
was last week at the barber shop with my
son okay
um so i walk into the barbershop and
there's three men waiting to get
haircuts
and
one i'm figuring out while they're
talking they're talking about ukraine
and russia of course but they start
talking about other things and the one
guy sitting next to me he says i'm
jewish and i don't remember what he said
but he said he as a jewish person this
than the other and the guy next to him
goes i don't understand why jewish
people don't vote for don't like trump
because they're democrat i mean the what
of what the democrats have done to the
jewish people and i'm sitting here
trying to bite my lip not to say
anything right but
i said i did eventually say something i
was like well um i know from what i know
jewish people tend to be left-leaning
and then they were talking about um
jewish people being secular and it went
into it went into all kinds of things
yeah i mean there's a lot of meaty stuff
in there you're basically right i mean
a recent poll of american jews found
that i think it's only like 22 percent
or 26
believe in god so that's a pretty that
is a pretty secular group
um and also it's one of the most liberal
voting blocs i think it's close to 80
percent of jews tend to vote for
democrats so both both of those things
are true
oh that's even interesting i didn't know
the specific stats but i guess i was
right
that jewish people tend to be
left-leaning oh yeah
and he also said something about
the anti-semitism on the left i guess
and and i went on to say well there's
anti-semitism coming from both sides at
times you were right you're absolutely
right
and then the uh the third guy was very
he seemed very religious
and he was talking about religion and
stuff and talking then he started
talking about islam and he was saying oh
islam islamic people are
um they're very
violent and i had to chime in and say
well no that's the extremists
ryan i was like that's the extremist
that's not everybody yeah that's very
violent so you can't say that that all
islamic people are muslim people are
violent of course
it sounds like you handled it quite well
i have to say i was trying the last
thing the um they're all talking and i'm
like well i'm a teacher so the guy
the guy who said the thing about trump i
don't know why people don't like trump
he goes teachers are sheep and i was
like well i take offense to that because
i'm a teacher and i almost find myself
being a sheep right and he's like well
not all teachers but a lot of them and
you probably are too he says to me and
i'm like okay wow
so then i i you know i had to chime in
and say well guess what i don't i think
trump was horrible and i don't i don't
like him at all
so the guy's like so then the the things
go left and he's like what are you crazy
you don't like trump of that what
everything he's done
and he and everything he's done for your
people and i'm like what's your who's
your people i don't i don't know what he
meant by that i guess he might because
i'm um not white i don't know what he
meant but i think that's exactly what he
meant
yeah i think so too but i really didn't
address that part because i didn't want
to go into the weeds with that yeah well
but you know one thing that's useful to
say in those cases is to say what
exactly did he do and see if if they can
even name anything
well he did say he brought back so many
jobs to america
from where i was like well he did
outsource a lot of jobs too yeah
that was the and then he went on to say
that i'm brainwashed and i was like okay
i'm brainwashed but meanwhile prior to
that he has mentioned i don't really
follow politics and i was like well i do
and you say you don't follow politics so
i don't know who would be the one who's
more brainwashed yeah this is like that
ufc dude we covered who gave a press
conference on saturday and he was like
listen
i don't know what's going on in ukraine
and russia i just don't know i just know
i'm not going over there but biden and
his son have made all sorts of money you
know it's like i thought you just said
you didn't know anything about it but
people who don't know anything still
have many opinions i guess is what we're
learning exactly it was basically the
same kind of scenarios i remember you
talking about that what uh what
neighborhood was this in
i live in um throgs neck in the bronx
this is like frog's neck pelham bay area
i live in aoc's district actually gotcha
person which is weird i don't know how
she makes it into congress but look and
it's very trumpy over here where i live
as well
it sounds wild was the haircut at least
okay
yes he looked handsome he looked
that's good it wasn't the barbers it was
the customers so right i understand i
understand
but i just wanted to share that crazy
story what what's your tipping policy on
haircuts these days
um actually my son um i don't know i i
really honestly don't know i think they
overcharged me for the haircut which i
didn't i didn't realize because i was
too busy talking sorry and i was giving
my son the money so i wasn't paying
attention but i i try to tip um
five to ten dollars that's a blink
and i have to tip for two because i have
two kids so i have to tip for each
person that'll add up that'll add up
quick
yes
well tamisha you've really said it all i
appreciate your call
thanks for taking my call all right
there we go tamesha from the bronx
always great to hear from her always
always great to hear from her
let's go next to
i hope i pronounce this correctly
is it cheaty or chidi from helsinki
finland
yeah that's true chidi how are you
doing all right how about yourself good
and are you are you finnish
yeah i was uh born in finland lived
there for a few years and then
uh moved to southern california so i
grew up in socal but oh okay yeah you
sound like a socal guy i was gonna say
i hope that's a good thing yeah
absolutely but so do you get back to
finland
yeah yeah yeah so i did my military
conscription uh back in 2013. oh wow
spent most summers in finland um and i'm
actually in finland right now so oh
you're in finland wow and
you i i can only assume you love that
salmon soup they have in finland right i
have to ask
oh it's fantastic it's the best it's the
best i don't know what they do but that
deal they put in it's just extraordinary
yes uh
definitely intrinsic to finnish culture
so uh put dill on everything absolutely
all right well what's on your mind today
yeah uh so i'm just kind of curious what
your take is on social media and
misinformation um obviously social media
bears
a lot of responsibility for the spread
of misinformation um it results in
radicalization and um has had un
imaginable consequences so i'm kind of
curious what your take is on you know
how we move forward obviously social
media wasn't very prevalent even 20
years ago
it's a pretty modern technology and
with the way that congress is and how a
lot of these congress people are
pretty old and are not very up to date
with um modern technology i'm kind of
curious
what you believe is kind of the path
forward as far as
um ensuring that the spread of
misinformation doesn't become uh
an even bigger problem than it is
already
so my view uh on this is um oh hold on
we have i have a situation here uh hold
on a second i'm being told that we're
having a situation
um outside my place so here's my view i
do not believe that we are going to
regulate our way out of this problem i
don't believe that the solution is going
to come from anything other than
educating people
so they never fall for the bs to begin
with and the problem is we're fighting
the right in just about every state we
have to be teaching media literacy and
critical thinking starting at age 10
everywhere
and we i don't know
uh
how
we make that happen but i think that's
really you've got to go to the source
because when we think about any
technology and neil postman writes about
this
the potential for the spread of
misinformation through social media
can't be eliminated out for as long as
social media exists so you've just got
to give people the tools not to fall for
it that's that's my view i just don't
think you're going to regular you're
going to regulate your way out of it
yeah i've heard you speak about um
educating through media literacy
what would something like that
look like in terms of the coursework or
right like is this something you would
teach in schools is this something that
like you would expect parents to
teach through like socialization like
i'm just kind of curious what that
process listen in an ideal world at a
very so kids when they are two or three
advertising starts to work on them and
they don't even necessarily know the
difference between like the program and
the advertisement so in
in my ideal world
parents would always have a narrative
about understanding what it is we're
watching and not everything is true and
here's how you think for yourself and
all these different things it's not
realistic that every parent is going to
be equipped to do that so i think that
it needs to be part of school curricula
i don't see any other way
right
yeah it seems like those who are
most susceptible to
the influences of social media actually
get it through their parents though kind
of moving forward it seems like those
who you would want to educate
in social media and media literacy would
be getting that kind of misinformation
from their parents
in some cases it's not only the parents
won't be the ones teaching it it's the
parents will be the one disseminating
the misinformation that's very sad
that's a shame to quote donald trump
yeah yeah very much so awesome well
thank you very much i appreciate it all
right i appreciate the call great to
hear uh great to hear from finland i
mean we love we love finland obviously
a couple super chats here david how are
you just showing join your youtube
membership do you think the usa will get
oil and gas from a different nation
other than russia probably do a peace
treaty from venezuela i don't know yet
i don't know i i have not been following
that closely enough
let's go to drew from fort lauderdale
drew i'm going to be down in fort
lauderdale very very soon
outstanding sir yeah i haven't been i've
been to fort lauderdale once
when i was a kid i i'm gonna be up front
i did not love it but i'm gonna be down
there doing some shows and podcasts and
some of them are right in the fort
lauderdale area
be prepared it's super scorching hot i'm
ready you know i'm ready for that and
also i am uh
i've got some good i'm going to dinner
with a couple people sounds like there's
some pretty good restaurants down there
at least so it should be a good time
absolutely yes it will be a good time
good
well i just wanted to ask you real quick
what's your stance on sending uh
poland's mig jet fighters to ukraine i
know they've already ruled it out but
what i i
apologize if you've already gone over at
one of your shows no you know what i i
haven't gone over it and to be totally
honest i don't have an opinion on it
because i haven't followed it closely
enough like what what's the controversy
can you explain it to me
they're saying that it they don't want
it they think that it'll be an
escalatory action they who are worried
uh the united states oh okay and nato
and nato they said that that'd be a step
too far
that if we provide them with those those
migs
that putin and they're even talking
about saying you know he could go
nuclear on us and we cannot risk that we
cannot risk that type of escalation
yeah um so i mean listen here's the
thing
uh
in a sense it it would be potentially
escalatory
at the same time
if
the parties involved are worried enough
about what putin's going to do next such
that they believe sending the migs is a
preparation for defense then you kind of
have to do it i mean i don't think you
can be guided by how a madman will react
to you to some degree
hey and we're kind of like giving up the
you know we're kind of like letting him
dictate
as opposed to us dictating indeed what's
gonna happen indeed and that's why i'm
for the no-fly zone as well well the
no-fly zone is tough because what do you
the thing about the no-fly zone is
anybody can make a no-fly zone but it's
about enforcing the no-fly zone and what
we're talking about is is shooting
people down and killing them at the end
of the day so so that that's a that's a
major step i don't know about that i
mean i'm not saying yes or no i'm just
saying it's more than just oh we should
just do it like that's not you don't
off-handedly do a no-fly zone
it's just my feeling on it is this is
where we need to be strong we said never
again after world war ii it's happening
again
and we've already given them thousands
of javelins which have killed which have
destroyed hundreds of uh vehicles and
killed you know hundreds of russian
soldiers already yeah and
we said we're gonna give them what they
need he's begging zlinski's begging for
these these these jets
do you want biden to go back on no boots
on the ground or do you want him to
stick to that
i want him to stick to that okay we have
the the most awesome air force the hit
in the history of mankind
there's no way i believe
that
if we shot down a couple of their their
rush the russian jets
i guarantee you that the russian jet
fighter pilots will think twice about
going over that airspace regardless of
what they're being told
it sounds to me like i mean listen i am
not pretending to know the answer here i
know that the the the no-fly zone will
lead to significant death and not just
the the fighter pilots but it'll lead to
death on the ground as well from what
i'm reading so i just think we got to be
very very careful about that
i really appreciate that you talking to
me about this and have a great time down
here and again don't bring anything but
shorts t-shirt flip-flops that's all you
need absolutely absolutely thank you so
much drew i appreciate it
thanks david all right there's drew from
fort lauderdale i do want to say thank
you to pepper love and kitty pepper love
and kitty our new members 53 and 54. and
a huge thank you to barbara fusco who
just signed up with the coupon code
please don't war
on my website
robert says via super chat i wish i
could put into words how much i
appreciate what you do sir you have
become a cornerstone in our news cycle
here at home
thank you very much well thank you sir i
appreciate that
let's go next to
uh david leibowitz this isn't this isn't
david leibowitz from paris france is it
oh um no this is not david lewis from
paris france oh okay well welcome david
yes i didn't actually expect to be
called on but i didn't either
well i've been i've been watching your
show for many many years and it's a
great uh i guess thank you uh
i guess what i guess i think it's been
talked about a lot but in talking about
bringing up these ideas about um
conservatives now trying to bash biden
over um his use of oil policies and how
that relates to
um
this this this fake idea that that that
biden is being brainwashed by aoc um
what is that i've not even heard that
who says briden's brainwashed by aoc he
seems to barely pay attention to her
no um i believe there's a fox host kyle
kolinsky um
kyle kalinski who like brought up i
think i'm thinking like fox host kyle
kalinski what wait well hold on let's
back
wait not [ __ ] no fox who's kyle kalinski
play if you had uh just
brought up a fox oh kyle brought up that
a fox host mentioned it i see what
you're saying okay okay okay yeah yeah
they said it was aoc's war i see um yeah
but basically i guess what is the best
and worst way to respond to the oil
crisis at the moment
did you hear that noise was that a
vibrating phone what was that you know
oh my god and now we got discord going
there's a lot happening over there isn't
there david
oh my god hello
can you hear me or what's going on
i can hear you yeah okay
so listen
here's the deal um
the president can do very little about
the gas prices and i've talked about
that before
so there's really at the end of the day
two things that have to be done and
these are not necessarily easy things to
do
number one
anybody
who is impacted by the increased price
of oil
is going to have to deal with it and i'm
not saying that in a glib way to say
it's going to be no big deal but what i
mean is
keystone xl is not going to lower the
price of gasoline and heat home heating
oil
um you know so part one is we're now in
a situation where we're this dependent
on oil and the price is going up and
people are going to have to deal with it
and tough it out and i'm not saying that
that's gonna be easy
and number two
this should be a reminder that we gotta
get off the oil we've gotta start
transitioning to electric vehicles
and electric home heating which can be
powered by solar it can be powered by
wind it can be powered by geothermal
although geothermal is not considered
renewable in the same sense so okay
that's what we got to do and it it's so
it's underwhelming because it's not
going to fix anything today for anybody
it's like i know that but we should have
done it five years ago and 10 years ago
and so on and so forth so that's that's
the solution presidents can do very
little about gas prices
i guess on a i'm personally actually
studying to be a psychologist so in your
in your in specifically or definitely
around um some parts about messaging um
but how would you say to win the
messaging or over this as climate is
even being obviously mocked in the news
but at least has actually been brought
up in the news how do we take advantage
of this moment
um i mean if so
if the left were smart and well funded
like the right
they would be funding every single think
tank and political analyst and whatever
and getting big pr dollars to get them
booked on every show possible to say
this is why we've been talking about
green energy and electric vehicles and
getting off of fossil fuels
if we were off of them or off of them to
a great degree
we wouldn't be in this gas price crisis
because we would be able to say well
we're not really using that much gas
here so i i mean i think you would have
to throw a ton of money at it and get
the people on cable radio tv etc
messaging around that they're just not
doing it every once in a while someone's
like i don't know maybe do some more
electric vehicle chargers or something
but you've got to throw a lot of money
at it
well thank you my pleasure great to hear
from you
all right there he goes david leibowitz
uh powerful insights
let's go
next to
let's go to dre from georgia dre
go
hey pleasure to be speaking with you
david i've been watching you for a
couple years so i really appreciate the
opportunity thank you my pleasure
but on to my question so um how do you
think the ukraine situation is going to
affect the left electorally because the
american population is bipartisanly in
support of the american support of
ukraine except uh organizations such as
the dsa have been pushing for nato to
leave or the u.s to leave nato which is
an extremely unpopular position and uh
some of their members like jamal bowman
in new york city has been receiving
pushback for that stance so i'm curious
what do you think about that i think
that uh the dsa is so small in the
united states right now and its impact
is so uh minor
that for me
i'm seeing most americans approve of joe
biden's response and handling of the
ukraine crisis so far
um and most democrats are on board with
that and so i see it as in for 2022 now
the question in six months might be
different but as of right now it seems
to me that it would certainly not hurt
democrats in 22 and it might help and i
even saw some recent
polling which shows that all of a sudden
democrats have a better shot at
retaining control in 2022 than at any
point in the last year doesn't mean they
will
but uh i i think that so far uh it's all
been not negative and potentially
positive for democrats
or that's not exactly what i meant when
i asked a question so oh when you said
electorally i thought i thought you
meant in the upcoming election
oh sorry i meant more like the
progressive left so people like your
aocs and all that because i do think
this is benefiting the democrats as a
whole yeah but i think the progressive
contingency of the democrats might get
hit by this in like 2022 midterms and
2024 because
like jamal bowman who i mentioned who's
aggressive democrat yeah he might get
primaried for example by a more moderate
democrat for his stance on this that may
happen i mean i i
it's i'm just not even really aware of
it because it's getting
almost like the first i've even heard of
this is from you
so i can't speak to jamal bowman maybe
he'll get primaried maybe he maybe he
will lose i'm just not sure but it's i
i've not even heard this disgust to be
perfectly honest
that's totally fair it's just uh
maybe i'm looking into a little too much
but i definitely appreciate you uh uh
picking up the call my pleasure thanks
dre uh great to talk to you
great to talk to you too all right
there's dre from georgia let's speak to
a couple other people
uh
what's uh let's see what's a place we
haven't heard from recently
there's so many different places oh you
know what it was my fault earlier with
shayna from california so i'm going to
go back to shaina shayna that was my
fault earlier i apologize
oh god shayna you're completely
digitized or digitized your voice is uh
something's wrong with your yeah they
have a great connection oh my god
they're pretty weak
oh can you hear me david sir i can hear
you ma'am yes i can hear you but it's
it's very it sounds almost like um
i don't even know what to call them like
they're like technical noises
yeah our connection's kind of weak but
now it's better now it's better
okay great okay first of all regarding
the jesse smilet case i hope uh i hope
he does get jail time for what he did
because
he's just making uh the actual making it
harder for actual hate crime victims i'm
with you one hundred percent shaina
just like a fine any false police report
be it
a hate crime sexual assault finally
republic police report makes it a lot
harder for the actual victims because
it's changed their credibility
you are laying out the case beautifully
i'm with you 100
why why would he do that
that i don't know does anybody know i
mean do you know why he did this i don't
even know why he did it
me neither i can't put my finger on it
yeah i especially can't believe he hired
nigerians to do it i mean
right if you want to claim white guys
attacked you you got to hire white guys
to attack you i think i don't know i
mean i'm no criminal genius either but
it seems like a basic thing
absolutely david and um
another thing um do you really think how
far do you think putin will go
do you think he's someone with nothing
left to lose i mean i think the question
is how far will he be allowed to go
shayna
i'm
still a little bit nervous yeah with
everything you know them taking the
nuclear plants
i know there might be a tactical reason
but still sends a chill up my spine i
agree with you you're following this
pretty closely it seems
as closely as i can yeah
well it's uh you're you've really said
it all what remind me which area of
california you're in
sacramento oh sacramento that's right
that's right and it's it gets quite hot
there does it not
sorta yeah oh speaking of which there
was a woman in sacramento who
faked her kidnapping she was caucasian i
forgot her name but
a fake kidnapping did she hire someone
or she just called in a fake kidnapping
it wasn't a hire it was uh she was
actually spending some time with her uh
her lover she's married you see
so she sees that seems like a perfect
example of it might sound like a good
idea but you have no off ramp from that
that makes any sense
i'm just saying um the conservatives
might be a little bit silent about that
because she's caucasian
uh-huh okay well and while she didn't
hire the person
she just lied and made it up on the fly
because
she didn't want people to find out she's
being on her husband
i just want to say the conservatives
keep that energy for her you know keep
the energy shayna i appreciate it you're
going back to robot voice so i'm gonna
keep going with the calls but it's
really great to hear from you
again all right see you later david okay
see ya there's shayna from sacramento
what what a great uh we love hearing
from shaina let's go to gabriella from
brussels now is that brussels belgium
yes david that is brussels belgium one
of my favorite cities in the world
you gave me the umido recommendation
right right right right right it was
excellent how are things
going uh good we just got masks uh are
no longer required outside of public
transportation
so
so hold on let me see if you're saying
oh they are still required on public
transportation but nowhere else
but nowhere else yeah so university
restaurants everything and do you feel
good about that
um
well i'm actually i had coveted about a
month ago and i still have
some
breathing and coughing issues so and i'm
boosted so i think the
for me i mean i have all the immunity i
think i can get at this point okay i
definitely feel differently about covet
after having it myself so that's fair
that's fair
yeah and are um are people who continue
to wear masks are they stigmatized and
shamed or is it just no big deal
everybody can do whatever they want
oh it's
absolutely no big deal i mean i think
all of i mean mostly in europe
i mean i've lived in italy now and
belgium and
there's no stigma around
i mean in the general population around
uh caring about covet or not caring i
mean it's very i think everyone cares to
an extent and it's just very normalized
that's great i mean i think that's
fantastic there's states in the u.s
where
if you uh wear a mask you know you're
you're kind of ridiculed actually
yeah i mean i spent some time this
summer in indiana to visit a family and
i felt that
um here's another recommendation for you
a restaurant called nordsie excellent
excellent seafood place in brussels oh
that's the seafood okay i've seen it i
haven't been but actually i'm craving
some fish so i think i'll go it's
fantastic and i highly recommend the
razor clams
okay i'll put that in my google maps
list please please so i actually called
because there's something from the oil
crisis that's going on now there's a
part of the analysis that i really
haven't seen anyone mention and that's
the 1973
oil crisis that we experienced
under nixon yes when the arab countries
embargoed oil in the u.s and there was a
consumption limit
and people were lining for hours to get
oil and i'm just i feel frustrated when
i watch analysis and they're like this
has never happened in the united states
of america well but there's there's some
key differences i mean you bring up a
good point which is it was an oil crisis
that's that's true the difference is
that was so now we have a situation
where there's there's plenty of supply
they get there's the gas is available
it's just people are getting frustrated
that it's expensive
so
there's no reason right now i mean right
now if you were to say we're gonna cap
how much gas you can buy if anything it
would probably make the prices shoot up
even more because it's uncertainty and
it would cause chaos
in 73 there were limits on how much you
could buy because of supply issues it
was more driven by as a supply issue
than primarily a price issue
okay yeah that makes actually i didn't
think about that it makes a lot of sense
i just wish that there was
uh i i hate the term like this doesn't
happen in america and this has never
happened before and i really wish that
there would be more like historical
memory there that actually i don't know
you know things with oil have happened
before in the u.s things with oil have
happened i think that that's fair there
have been oil spills we had the
transition to avocado oil and you know
there's been all sorts of oil related
news that's absolutely true lovely a
lovely transition yeah i would say so i
would say so gabriella thank you i
appreciate the call
my pleasure there's gabriella from
brussels hopefully she can report back
about uh
about nordsey other super chats sir how
is a no-fly zone considered offensive
when considering the atrocities being
committed oh no no no listen so uh
taylor i want to be very clear
um
what i said was it's completely
plausible that russia will see it as an
act of aggression but what dictates
whether it's done can't be how a lunatic
will react to it that's that's my only
point that's my only point
have you heard anything about the guys
on trial for conspiring to kidnap the
governor of michigan i have not been
following that
the excuses they were lured into it by
the fbi while stoned i should i should
follow what's going on with that kevin
rick says what do you leave biden can do
to relieve the price of petrol almost
nothing almost nothing le i'm gonna i
know that now i've done this ten times
but there are three things that a
president can do to impact the price of
gas number one
invade an oil producing nation
which will raise the price of gas
number two
raise or lower gas taxes which i don't
even think they can do unilaterally but
they can push for that to be done if you
raise gas taxes the price of gas goes up
if you lower gas taxes okay you know
what happens and number three
um release oil from the strategic
petroleum reserve which over the short
term can have an impact of from what i'm
reading 15 to 20 cents per gallon that's
what a president can do and i guess you
know stop buying oil from somewhere else
which is which is what we're doing with
uh what what the the world is really the
west is doing with with russia
um
the president can can really uh do do
very little as far as that goes
all right let's chat where do we want to
go next
how about
how about let's see i'm trying to look
for someone i've not spoken to before
let me try sammy from new york city
sammy you're on either way but have we
spoken before
sammy from new york city you're on
oh boy
sammy from new york city last chance to
unmute
that's too bad all right let's go
instead
to
uh
matthew from oregon matthew you're on
the air hey david can you hear me i can
hear you fine
hey david uh so i just wanted to talk
about uh so i'm in school studying
political science
and
i've seen a lot about like with like
local elections like for school boards
and for
you know library board and stuff like
that that like conservatives and
republicans seem to have
they put they put a lot more effort into
those elections and like progressives
and democrats like don't really as much
do you have any
like sort of insight on like what
democrats can do to like get more
involved other than just like spending
the money or is there is that oh it's
it's spending the money and deciding to
do it and training people and
i mean uh you know this it's like if we
did to the school boards not with the
insanity i just mean if respectfully
right if we did our version with school
boards of what they did to school boards
with the masks maybe we'd have more
school districts teaching critical
thinking and media literacy you know
it's like it's
it's just it's a failure of effort and
it's a failure of funding as well i'm
not denying that it's a money thing
okay yeah so so you think that that it's
a money but it's also an organizational
issue that that people that care just
don't care enough about like actually
going to the meetings and stuff yeah i
don't want to say people don't care but
it's people don't know or they're not
sure how to organize it or they don't
understand the importance or it doesn't
occur to them you know i don't want to
characterize it but it's not happening
is the most important takeaway
yeah okay yeah yeah
that that's where that's sort of my idea
is so do you have any idea
of you know what can be done from like a
higher organizational level or do you
think that sort of needs to come from
the grassroots we've just got to do what
the right does which is start spending
the money
build the organizations that will
explain to young people and people of
all ages here's what you have to do
here's what you have to do in your
community you've got to show up and the
way they organize to say we don't want
masks on our kids
we have to be organizing to show up and
say
uh we want
y z um it's it's the exact same thing
but it's
for for causes that are actually
worthwhile
okay yeah hey thanks for uh giving your
input on that my pleasure uh matthew
from oregon thank you so much for the
call all right everybody that's gonna do
it for calls today and that's gonna do
it for the stream
i will be back with all of you very soon
if not tomorrow
saturday for the next trump rally 2022
is on the way and these are candidate
endorsement rallies and it's gonna be a
lot a lot a lot a lot and remember
uh donald trump's favorite song hold on
i'm coming exactly and we will see
everybody on saturday at the very latest